bonjour célia avec vous nous allons donc
voir comment décorer son sapin pour noël
il faut faire preuve de créativité oui
alors je me suis rendu donc aux fermes
de gally à saint cyr l'école là-bas un
chalet de noël a été construit pour
l'occasion avec énormément de décoration
pour votre sapin et votre intérieur
alors pour décorer ce fameux arbre de
noël il y a quatre étapes et la première
celle à guérande électrique
on commence généralement par le bas de
telle sorte que la rallonge ce soit
pratique à brancher sur le sur le
secteur sur la prise électrique et on va
monter la guirlande électrique petit à
petit sans hésiter à rentrer à
l'intérieur du sapin si on arrive à la
fin de la guirlande au milieu du sapin
c'est pas un souci on va intégrer une
seconde guirlandes en faisant tomber la
rallonge au centre du sapin pour qu'elle
aille en bas et puis on va continuer
d'installer la guirlande à l'intérieur
et en périphérie du sapin ça va je me
débrouille pas trop mal quand j'entends
ces conseils est ce qu'il ya des
couleurs aussi à privilégier
oui oui il y a des couleurs la tendance
cette année c'est le retour au
traditionnel avec du rouge associé à du
blanc et du bois mais les trois couleurs
phare reste toujours le rouge le vert et
les dorés donc là il ya plein de
branchages plein de 12.2 fleurs de
branches de coton le troisième élément
qu'on va positionner savent être toutes
les petites guirlandes de perles qui
vont en iran en périphérie du sapin et
on finit par les boules de telle sorte
qu'elles soient passionnés sur le devant
et qu'elles soient bien visibles lumière
avec lumière mis en examen points avec
célia en direct si vous nous suivez à 18
heures j'étais un peu vite en besogne
parce que une fois la lumière installé
et encore de choses à faire
oui c'est ça dont on parlait donc de
lumière mais aussi les éléments donc à
tiquer aussi et puis bien sûr les
tendances de l'année c'est ces trois
couleurs là aussi sur ce coup vers laon
où on est sûr de pas se tromper parce
que c'est vraiment l'un des marqueurs
forts de noël et puis après on a des
des univers qui sont assez froids blanc
et bleu qui sont aussi très sympathique
mais qui sont moins chaleureux que le
rouge ou d'auray
et jusqu'à quand garder son sapin c'est
toujours la grande question
oui ben alors finalement jusqu'au 25
décembre minimum après souvent on garde
son sapin jusqu'au 1er janvier mais film
a finalement il n'y a pas de règle
chacun fait comme il veut merci beaucoup
coeliakie bonne décoration à vous